[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ty here and this is the Samsung Galaxy
Note 20. it's like the the little
brother of the Galaxy Note 20 Ultra that
I just reviewed but as a package this is
a very weird phone it's a very confused
phone but let's just back up for a
second first of all I bought this phone
from b h for with with tax and shipping
included
1086 dollars
but after using this phone for a bit it
feels like Samsung never really made up
their mind on if this was supposed to be
a premium phone or not like for a
thousand bucks you would think this
should be a premium phone for sure right
but as you use the phone and go down the
list of features and specs slowly that
feels more and more off like every
meaningful feature is cut down a bit
from the note 20 Ultra like the screen
for example if that's where we start
it's a little bit smaller but no big
deal it's still 6.7 inches and it's even
flat on the edges which I honestly
prefer and Samsung still gives you a lot
of the edge display features minus Edge
lighting which I don't think anyone
considers a necessary feature but it's
1080P and 60 hertz then has a slightly
larger hole punch cut out for the same
10 megapixel selfie camera and the same
ultrasonic fingerprint reader underneath
now the 1080p resolution okay fine I can
deal with that after all I actually set
the resolution on the Note 20 Ultra to
1080p but that's because you have to to
get 120 hertz but okay even if visually
1080p is fine you still get the great
colors and the brightness of the Samsung
panel and it's still really thin bezels
and to me it honestly looks great for
most things and if you're not a stickler
for refresh rate it's no big deal
watching videos and taking photos and
all that stuff is Awesome on this screen
but for the price for a thousand bucks
on a flagship in 2020 you should get a
high refresh rate screen right
but that's not the worst part of this
phone the upgraded S Pen is physically
the same on this note 20 as the ultra
but the latency doesn't drop as much
because it is still a 60hz display so it
drops from 42 to 26 milliseconds not all
the way down to the nine milliseconds of
the ultra understandable I absolutely
did not notice it's still incredibly
fast and responsive and does all the
same stuff I talked about in the Ultra
review it's definitely not the worst
part of this phone the camera array is
also cut down and different as you might
have been able to guess from the
significantly smaller camera bump so
instead of the ultra's huge 108
megapixel primary camera and the
Periscope 5x optical zoom you have a far
more reasonable 12 megapixel main Camera
12 megapixel Ultra wide and 64 megapixel
3x zoom and the photos and videos from
these cameras are honestly very similar
to the ones from note 20 Ultra Samsung
has a look a very pretty colorful
saturated HDR look that I do like and
this phone also accomplishes that look
and there's even again some advantages
to this system the not so giant sensor
focuses quickly without even needing
laser autofocus but while you keep 8K
video it also does cut down some of the
other highest end Ultra features like
the 108 megapixel mode the 50x space
Zoom only goes to 30X Max but again if
most people just point and shoot and 30X
is Enough from the back row of the
bleachers to catch your kid out on the
far side of the soccer field then
honestly most people probably won't miss
these couple of bleeding edge features
the camera is not the worst part of this
phone so okay let's take a look then at
this spec sheet so Snapdragon 865 Plus 8
gigs of RAM 128 gigs of non-explainable
storage 4 300 milliamp hour battery
okay so let's break this down so
Snapdragon a65 plus and eight gigs of
RAM as the only spec that's high end
it's cut down a bit from the 12 gigs of
RAM on the ultra but you know this
should still offer high-end performance
without a doubt and it does then 4 300
milliamp hour battery again fine
actually it is slightly smaller than the
note 20 ultra's battery but this is of
course a slightly smaller phone and
since it's only a 1080p 60hz display
which is usually the biggest sucker of
battery you're actually looking at a
slightly better overall battery life on
a charge than the ultra so that's fine
but 128 gigs as the only spec of
non-expandable storage at least in the
US
feels a bit small and you know maybe
some people are totally okay with this
but on a thousand dollar phone
where you expect probably use the
cameras all the time take a lot of
photos where you can take 8K videos and
there's tons of games and apps you would
just think you would give at least 256.
the Snapdragon note 20 Ultra weirdly has
a 128 or 512 internally but at least the
ultra has expandable storage via a Micro
SD card slot this phone doesn't have
that so maybe on the ultra where you
could get away with 128 on this one
that's all you get so the specs overall
while they're still high end they're
definitely starting to feel the squeeze
of the slightly lower price here but
that's still not the worst part of this
phone so you have the cut down specs the
cut down battery the cut down storage
the cut down cameras the cut down
display but none of this makes headlines
quite like the cut down materials
this phone is plastic now okay plastic
gets a bad wrap on smartphones I'm
guilty of not really ever being a huge
fan of plastic but I will say plastic
has its place in the smartphone World
we've all heard Zack say glass is a
glass and glass breaks glass is more
expensive and more fragile so on phones
like the pixel 4A for example you'll
never hear me complain that they chose
plastic and the plastic here on the Note
20 is even a little more Satin and a
little more reflection reverse than the
ultra it does a great job of hiding
fingerprints and all the micro scratches
that you usually get with plastic and at
the risk of sounding like I'm defending
it this plastic actually has some
advantages over glass like this huge
phone now actually feels and is much
lighter which can make a previously
unwieldy Ultra phone suddenly feel a
little bit more manageable and of course
it's less likely to shatter and at the
end of the day when you guys told me
that 80 percent of you use a case on
your phone no matter what then I guess
whether it was the glass note 20 Ultra
or the plastic of the note 20 people
were just going to put a case on this
anyway so I guess it just makes sense
for that to be one of the areas where
Samsung decided that they should save
money so even this phone being made of
plastic is still not the worst part of
this phone the worst part about the
Galaxy Note 20. is the launch price they
picked of a thousand dollars there is no
way this phone should ever justifiably
be a thousand dollars out of your pocket
as flossy Carter would say the price is
too damn high but see the thing is this
phone is actually not that bad but when
you combine this phone with that note
branding and that thousand dollar price
it gets very confusing but if you just
step back and remove the price and the
note name I mean this is a pretty unique
phone you get the S Pen you get wireless
decks you get the Samsung feature set
there really isn't anything out there
that quite matches it in terms of
features it just should have been like
seven hundred dollars instead of a
thousand I genuinely think Samsung was
confused like they they weren't they
didn't make up their mind on if they
were going to make a premium phone or
not like it starts off as a Galaxy Note
and Galaxy Notes are always high-end I
get that but I actually really like what
they did last year
not the rainbow reflection part but the
part where they made two different notes
for the first time the flagship high-end
one and then a slightly smaller but a
little bit more attainable version of
the same thing where they sort of
understood for the first time that
people didn't want to have to spend the
most money on the biggest phone but you
still get big screen stylus for not as
much money so then this year comes along
and they do the same thing they got
Galaxy Note Ultra high-end and then they
got another more attainable note which
is also in the note Series so still
high-end also has a Snapdragon 865 plus
so still high-end but then the rest they
just cut down too far plastic 1080p 60
hertz non-expandable 128 they cut down
too far so I think there's two
alternative paths they could have taken
probably should have taken with this
phone one would just be don't cut down
quite as much and commit to that
thousand dollar price point for this
phone you probably should include High
refresh rate and more base storage at
this point so 120 hertz like the rest of
Samsung's high-end lineup and 256 512 or
just put expandable storage in this
phone or two
just commit to making a more
competitively priced lower end Galaxy
Note like they could have just made this
the note 20 Lite or the note 20 e swap
out the Snapdragon 865 plus that big
expensive chip with the Snapdragon 765g
then you have a 700 phone that you can
compete big phone big stylus way lower
price like I think that would have been
really interesting and potentially
really great for this line and it
probably would have eaten alive a lot of
the sales of some of the other right
around 700 phones sitting at 1080p 60
hertz like LG velvet but I think the
reason Samsung didn't do that is because
that would have also been a little bit
confusing in their lineup to have a new
Galaxy Note sitting at a lower price
than some of the S Series and starts to
cannibalize some of those sales and also
just having a 600 price difference
between two notes is kind of of a lot
looks weird so as a result they sort of
straddled all this stuff and we ended up
with this slightly confusing terrible
deal of a thousand dollar plastic 1080p
60 hertz note 20. and I can't really
recommend most people buy this note 20
at this price as long as those other
phones like s20 plus and OnePlus 8 Pro
and others that are just more phone for
the same or less money but if you
absolutely need an S Pen and just can't
spend 1300 bucks I guess I'd say fine go
for it because instead of the Note 10
Samsung just now promised three major
Android updates for their flagships
starting now and it looks like note 10s
won't be getting that so if you're in
that tiny sliver and you gotta have the
S Pen then Samsung made this phone just
for you if you're not that person you
probably yeah nope you shouldn't buy
this phone either way that's been it
hope you enjoyed this episode of nope
Tech thanks for watching catch you guys
in the next one Peace So shout out to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video so
you guys already know how much I like
expressvpn but now they're letting me
give you a little bit of a sneak preview
of their new beta version so with this
expressvpn has done something pretty
much unprecedented in the VPN industry
so essentially they've built their own
protocol from scratch which might not
sound like much but if you check out
basically every other VPN what they've
done is they've taken an off-the-shelf
protocol and tweaked it to their own
needs which is kind of like picking a
video game character and some arcade
racing game where you know you can get
the maximum speed but that's obviously
going to have other guaranteed drawbacks
so building your own is kind of a big
deal so expressvpn developed lightweight
to fit exactly all of your needs without
these trade-offs now expressvpn has
already been fast and I've showed that
before but let me show you this real
quick this is me using lightweight to
connect to the Japan server which is
about 6 700 miles away and you can see
how much faster that was it and it
doesn't just connect faster I'm also
blown away by the speeds when I'm using
it too so it's pretty sweet and clearly
it works and it's coming to expressvpn
users very soon soon so bottom line is
it's a no-brainer for people to be using
expressvpn they're literally doing
things that no other VPN is even trying
lightweight like I said is in beta but
if you want to be among the first to
experience these new speeds
expressvpn.com
MKBHD is where you should go and you'll
get three free months when you sign up
there so thanks again to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video